dwarf goblins
i mean she literally looks like a goblin
i'm just telling you and acts like a
goblin just because you claim to think
something is true does not make it true
the jury awards almost 50 million
dollars in damages against alex jones
and his companies for defaming the
parents of children killed in the sandy
hook massacre after years of being
targeted by alex jones the parents
finally had their chance to address
jones to his face in court and things
did not go well for jones just how bad
was it so bad that former prosecutor
mitchell epner said in over 25 years as
a trial lawyer i have never seen a
witness do more damage to himself on the
stand than alex jones and that includes
a case where i was ausa where i got a
defendant to admit that he was guilty of
the crime charged in the indictment it
was so bad that also former prosecutor
ken white said it was like an action
movie where it's not enough that the bad
guy gets shot or stabbed at the end he's
got to be like decapitated and exploded
and impaled at the same time but let's
start at the beginning why was alex
jones on trial in 2012 a lone gunman
murdered six adults and 20 children at
the sandy hook elementary school in
newtown connecticut alex jones and his
associate alan troyer and wolfgang
helbig said that the event was a hoax
that did not happen the whole thing was
a giant hoax the jones gang accused the
bereaved family members of being quote
crisis actors and it just shows how bold
they are
that they clearly
used actors and jones and his
correspondents repeated those claims on
infowars broadcast okay so just another
question that people are now going to be
asking about sandy hook alex jones's
fans harassed the parents online and at
their homes and after several years of
this some of the sandy hook families
sued jones for defamation in connecticut
and texas during his deposition in one
of the other sandy hook cases lawyers
played clips of jones mocking the
parents and calling their tears bad
acting my problem is i've watched a lot
of stuff propers
and i've seen actors before
and i know when i'm watching the movie
when i'm watching something real and in
response to those clips jones admitted i
wrote that he knew his statements were
false after his deposition jones and
infowars denied having emails text
messages and other material about the
sandy hook claims
jones and his lawyers then ignored court
orders to produce documents in texas and
connecticut and spoiler alert during the
damages trial we found out that they
lied about having this material when one
of his lawyers accidentally sent
jones's entire cell phone and a whole
bunch of other documents to opposing
counsel your attorneys messed up and
sent me an entire digital copy of your
entire cell phone with every text
message you've sent for the past two
years and jones has a whole pattern of
disregarding discovery obligations in
other cases as well and some people have
claimed that jones has gotten railroaded
by having liability conceded
by default and that jones's
constitutional rights have been
infringed
that is not the case here uh here uh it
was a strategic choice by jones and his
attorney to not turn documents over all
the while claiming that they never
possessed relevant documents and that
those documents didn't exist we know now
that that is not the case that it was a
strategic choice to hold those documents
back never turn them over and then face
the repercussions
in court which is what they basically
have done and why liability was
conceited but i'm not going to seal the
entire quantity of information
without knowing what's in it when the
rules weren't followed properly and
taking all of that into consideration
the judges in all 10 sandy hook cases
entered default judgments against jones
and his companies a default judgment
happens when the defendant in a civil
case fails to do something
such as ignoring court summons missing a
court date or disregarding the judge's
direct orders and if this occurs a court
may rule in favor of the plaintiff by
default and this is very rare a default
judgment is the most serious sanction a
judge can impose during a civil trial
judges do not enter default judgments
very often but if you want to learn more
about why the default judgments were
entered against jones check out my video
on the topic i have an entire video on
the pre-damages portion of this trial
but this particular case that we're
talking about today is the first of
three upcoming trials that will decide
how much money jones and his companies
must pay in damages it was filed by neil
heslin and scarlett lewis who are the
parents of six-year-old jesse lewis who
was killed at sandy hook and since the
default judgments were issued jones
couldn't contest liability the trial was
only about how much jones must pay and
the plaintiffs sought 150 million
dollars in compensatory and punitive
damages so what did the plaintiff say
during trial well neil heslin was the
first plaintiff to testify i can't even
describe
the last nine and a half years of the
living hell
that
i and others have had to endure
because of the negligence and the
recklessness of alex jones he and lewis
said that strangers have confronted them
everywhere including at their homes
haslam's house and car have been shot by
people yelling out alex jones somebody
drove by my home yet shouting out the
window alex jones
and
sounded like gunfire coming from the
vehicle heslin gave heart-wrenching
testimony about holding his son and
seeing that he had a bullet hole through
his head owen troyer went on jones's
program and said that heslin lied about
holding his son's body i think it's time
for you to explain this contradiction in
the narrative and this is apparently
what prompted heslin and lewis to fight
back alex started this fight
and i'll finish this fight now jones
wasn't in court to hear heslin's
testimony about jesse it's not necessary
to show up to court but you know usually
you do want to do that
instead while heslin testified uh jones
did a live show where he called heslin
slow and autistic and accused him of
being manipulated by lawyers
he's slow okay
this was not a good strategy because
this clip was then played in court for
the jury just a few days later i mean i
didn't cancel and act like somebody on
the spectrum it supported one of the
plaintiff's key claims that jones has
spent years ridiculing the sandy hook
parents and that he can't control
himself or his employees who continue to
harass the families now after court
heslin and jones had a confrontation
where jones again called hesland a slow
person who was being manipulated by
lawyers jones also ripped the judge on
his infowars program and they're all
caricatures of what you would imagine in
some alternate universe of
dwarf goblins
it's demonic they all act demonically
possessed the judge the lawyers now part
of our job as lawyers is client control
we tell our clients not to talk about
their cases in public don't post on
facebook don't share things in the media
don't talk with friends and family but
ultimately though it's up to the client
to demonstrate some self-control judge
goblin here in austin
i mean she literally looks like a goblin
i'm just telling you
and acts like a goblin even the greatest
lawyers in history would probably be
powerless to stop jones from you know
being himself and then there was the
testimony of plaintiff scarlett lewis uh
jones was again not in court for the
first half of scarlett lewis's testimony
uh when he finally arrived he was
accompanied by a team of bodyguards uh
lewis addressed her testimony directly
to jones uh while he sat at the defense
table i am a mother first and foremost
and i know that you're a father
and my son existed
i know you believe me
and yet you're gonna get you're gonna
leave this courthouse
and you're gonna say it again on your
show at one point louis directly asked
jones do you think i'm an actress
no you can't talk right now sorry now
lewis told jones that he makes claims
about the massacre that he knows or lies
but when you say those things
there's a fringe of society that believe
you
that are actually dangerous and lewis
emphasized the deep trauma that she has
because of jones and his followers it
seems
so
incredible to me
that we have to do this
that we have to
implore you
not just import you
punish you
to get you to stop lying a forensic
psychologist who met heslin and lewis
said both suffer from a form of
post-traumatic stress disorder that
comes from constant trauma uh jones
lawyer reynold had a tough time handling
these witnesses on cross-examination
because it would be incredibly hard to
cross-examine these witnesses at one
point he suggested that it would be more
healing for lewis and heslin to sit down
and talk through the trauma with alex
jones than it would to file a lawsuit on
cross-examination jones's lawyer grilled
lewis about her finances noting her book
contract and speaking engagements can
you tell the members of the jury how
much is the suggested honorarium for
your speaking movement
um
it may be five thousand dollars
could ten be more accurate it could be
ten and he said that she makes more than
enough to pay for her own therapy now
i'm gonna go out on a limb here and say
that this question probably did not go
over particularly well with the jury and
then there's this testimony of alex
jones himself when he took the stand he
told plaintiffs that he's always wanted
to apologize that i never intentionally
tried to hurt you i never even said your
name until this case
came to court
i didn't even know who you were until a
couple years ago when all this started
up
the internet had a lot of questions i
had questions jones argued that he made
a few inquiries about whether sandy hook
was a false flag operation and then the
mainstream media reported on what he
said and turned everything into a circus
the media jones said created an
atmosphere where nobody knew what the
facts were so there was no real way for
him to get it right jones and his lawyer
argue that the sandy hook parents were
victimized four times by the shooter by
truthers by politicians and by everyone
else who took their grief and weaponized
it in other words it wasn't his fault
now on cross-examination jones also
admitted that he basically called every
major event of the last decade a false
flag incident engineered by the
government now the judge was not pleased
by any of this you've probably seen the
incendiary clips of the judge telling
jones to stop lying under oath you're
already under oath to tell the truth
you've already violated that oath twice
today now the judge admonished jones for
a number of different things the first
was telling the jury that he was
bankrupt uh jones repeatedly testified
that he only makes money selling uh
prepackaged uh prepper food for like an
apocalypse everything else uh was money
losing that he claimed but plaintiffs
had already shown that infowars was
making a lot of money as much as eight
hundred thousand dollars a day during
certain events and one of his employees
testified that the company makes about
uh 50 million dollars annually that's
what the document says though faced with
three upcoming trials jones and his
companies have started bankruptcy
proceedings now when a company files for
chapter 11 protection it tends to stay
the other legal proceedings jones has
many llc's but the biggest company is
free speech systems free speech systems
filed for bankruptcy in texas so jones's
lawyer moved to stay the the connecticut
proceedings which is a different case
but this was the second delay in the
connecticut case because of bankruptcy
maneuvers back in april infowars and two
of its subsidiaries infowars health llc
and prison planet llc also filed for
bankruptcy protection now these entities
were removed as named defendants so that
the damages proceedings could move
forward now free speech systems listed
14.3 million in assets including over a
million dollars in cash and almost 1.6
million in property in equipment however
the petition claimed the company had 79
million dollars in liabilities including
a 54 million debt owed to something
called pqpr holdings now who owns pqpr
holdings well it's carol jones and david
jones also known as alex jones's mom and
dad and the sandy hook plaintiffs
believe the bankruptcy proceedings are a
sham heslin posner and two other sandy
hook families
filed separate lawsuits accusing jones
of hiding millions of dollars in assets
the plaintiff said the 54 million debt
was dubious since pqpr is a nevada
registered company that is owned by
shell entities owned by jones's kids and
parents
there's substantial evidence of
fraudulent transfers and it's not even
clear that the bankruptcy court would
discharge the statehood judgments anyway
so while jones may delay it's likely to
be a pyrrhic victory and going back to
what jones was admonished for during the
trial jones told the jury that he had
complied with the court's discovery
orders which is absolutely false now
during discovery plaintiffs asked for a
number of different things but they
specifically asked jones to identify the
number of videos he produced about sandy
hook jones and his co-defendants refused
to produce this material which is one of
the reasons for the default judgment and
the plaintiff's lawyers generally had a
pretty easy time showing that alex jones
uh was lying about the stuff that was
actually produced
told the jury that there was 29 minutes
total open videos he played 51 minutes
in a single video so we know that's not
true he has routinely every single day
of this trial broken rules that a
first-year lawyer knows he has routinely
placed inadmissible material in front of
the jury it is from our perspective at
this table that mr renault is actively
trying for a mistrust and the judge told
alex jones's lawyer to stop many
different times i am very upset that you
have tried to
imply to the jury
that we know
how many videos about sandy hook were
released by your clients when we don't
because they refused to respond to
discovery so i do not want you to do
that again and and i don't want you to
argue with me about it that is the rule
of this case
that is the that's it they didn't
respond we don't know
we've had multiple conversations about
how i know you know what the rules are
and you know you know what the rules are
but you've chosen not to follow them on
occasion and despite the judge's very
clear instructions on the number of
videos reynold interrupted the judge to
argue the number of videos
their length
this is evidence that is being induced
but what you said was not
we've shown the jury 29 minutes of clips
where the word sandy hook appears or
anything like that it was
they released in total 29 minutes that
is not true but the judge made it
extraordinarily clear to alex jones uh
what he could and could not do you may
not say to this jury
that you complied with discovery
that is not true
you may not say it again
you may not tell this jury that you are
bankrupt that is also
not true
you're already under oath to tell the
truth
you've already violated that oath twice
today
in just those two examples
it seems
absurd to instruct you again that you
must tell the truth while you testify
yet here i am you must tell the truth
while you testify
this is not your show
you need to slow down
and not take what you see as
opportunities
to
further the message you're wanting to
further
and instead
only answer
the specific and exact question you have
been asked now what makes all of these
exchanges particularly remarkable is
that jones lawyer reynald probably knew
that there was a ticking time pom that
disproved jones's claims about discovery
ticking time bomb was that jones's
lawyer had accidentally sent 300
gigabytes of unredacted information
directly to plaintiff's council and that
included
jones's entire cell phone backup and
sure enough on cross-examination
plaintiff's lawyer bankston reminded
jones that he claimed to have searched
for messages related to sandy hook on
his phone jones said yes that he did the
search but found nothing so you did get
my text messages
and said you did nice trick and that led
to the perry mason moment where bankston
absolutely skewered jones on
cross-examination by pointing out that
these documents did exist in the form of
text messages and emails that mentioned
sandy hook
and the reason that bankston knew that
they existed is because jones's lawyer
accidentally sent him the entire cell
phone i see i told you the truth this is
your perry mason moment uh yeah that's
uh
that's quite the exchange and in fact i
have an entire video covering both this
perry mason moment and the equally
interesting uh hearing that was held the
next day where the defense counsel moved
for mistrial uh and that also did uh did
not go well for alex jones but since
liability was already conceded it didn't
really take the jury very long to award
damages to the plaintiffs the jury found
that alex jones should pay 4.1 million
dollars in compensatory damages for
repeatedly claiming the school shooting
was a hoax
now a court awards compensatory damages
to put the plaintiff in the situation
that they would have been had the harm
not occurred now competitory damages
include both economic and non-economic
damages such as medical bills lost wages
pain and suffering mental impairment and
emotional distress heslin and lewis were
seeking 150 million dollars from jones
but the jury's verdict fell pretty far
short of that mark jones lawyer reynold
asked jurors to award a total of eight
dollars one dollar for each of the eight
harms the defendants inflicted on heslin
and lewis of course he couldn't ask for
nothing because liability was conceded
now the jury's verdict was not unanimous
two of the jurors did not sign the form
in texas a civil jury verdict does not
have to be unanimous but that takes us
to the punitive damages or as texas
calls them exemplary damages now a court
will award exemplary damages in texas to
punish the wrongdoer for their
particularly bad behavior exemplary
damages are also meant to deter people
who might act like the defendant in the
future so in other words texas exemplary
damages are meant to penalize the
defendant for their behavior
and to warn others not to do the same
thing and under
section
41.003 of the texas code of practice and
remedies
exemplary damages are awarded to a
plaintiff if they prove with clear and
convincing evidence that their harm
resulted from fraud malice or gross
negligence but exemplary damages may
only be awarded if the decision is
unanimous this in combination with the
clear and convincing evidence standard
makes it difficult to recover exemplary
damages in personal injury cases in
texas but there's another wrinkle
because in texas there's a statutory cap
on punitive damages in personal injury
cases
an award of exemplary damages may not
exceed an amount
equal to the greater of two times the
economic damages plus an amount equal to
any non-economic damages found by the
jury not to exceed 750 000
or 200 000 and another subsection
prohibits telling the jury about this
particular cap now the reason the juries
are not instructed is that that might
influence their thinking they might
shift punitive damages into the
compensatory damages so it's entirely
possible that the jury can come up with
a much bigger amount than the statute
allows and if a jury returns an award
that is higher than the statutory cap
then the judge just simply reduces the
amount and in closing arguments the
plaintiff's attorney argued that this
was the jury's ability to send a message
to quote stop alex jones stop the
monetization of misinformation of lies
the defense argued that uh jones had
only spent 18 hours and 43 minutes
talking about sandy hook and that they
only made about 14 000 per hour
during the coverage and that should form
the basis of the award and following
closing arguments the jury returned a
verdict of 45 million dollars in
punitive damages but given the statutory
limits that we just talked about it's
likely that the punitive damages award
is likely to get chopped down to well
less than a million dollars but that
raises the question what's next for alex
jones well the answer is more trials on
september 14th the posner and delarosa
plaintiffs will face jones in texas
courtroom
in addition jones may find himself in
deeper trouble with the january 6
committee which wants to see all of the
information that was on his cell phone
which was turned over to the plaintiff's
attorneys
jones took the fifth amendment a hundred
times during his testimony to the
january six committee and in this trial
judge gamble said she would not enter an
order stopping bankston the plaintiff's
attorney from giving the material to the
january 6 committee i mean i don't know
that you get to stop that anyway
additionally jones's lawyers are in hot
water reynold is facing potential
discipline by the connecticut bar on the
same day that the texas jury handed down
the verdict a judge ordered reynald and
jones's lawyer norm pattis to attend a
hearing about whether they should be
referred to disciplinary authorities or
sanctioned by the court directly for
releasing confidential medical records
in violation of state and federal law
and the contra the court's protective
order and although jones told the jury
that any verdict over two million
dollars would sink us after the verdict
jones's lawyer assured reporters that
the verdict meant jones would continue
to be on the air presumably profitably
for the foreseeable future now the other
thing that could be next for alex jones
is a perjury conviction many people have
pointed out that it sure seems like
jones obviously lied on the stand aka
perjury and to find out about the law of
perjury and jones's chances of
conviction you'll have to head over to
today's sponsor nebula and curiosity
stream on nebula my videos always come
out early with zero ads and i release
exclusive content all the time like this
entire video on the implications of
jones's testimony and weather rises to
perjury as well as exclusive videos like
things people misunderstand about the
constitution why nfts are bad for
creators and my first full-length
documentary bad law words good and tons
more all exclusive to nebula and all of
this exclusive content is available only
on nebula which you can get for free
with curiosity stream nebula is creator
owned and creator operated and there's
new exclusive content released multiple
times every single day oh and by the way
we've been developing nebula like crazy
it now has apps for ios android apple tv
roku fire tv and android tv and it was
recently nominated for its first streamy
award my fellow creators and i really
care about nebula and we're thrilled to
be partnering with curiositystream
because they are the go-to source for
the best documentaries and long-form
educational content on the internet and
they even have an entire section devoted
to unsolved mysteries and crimes so if
you like my videos you will love the
thousands of titles on curiosity stream
now the best way to get access to nebula
and all of its incredible content is
through the amazing curiosity stream
nebula bundle deal with his current
sales price of less than 15 per year to
get access to both sites and to be clear
that nebulous subscription's not a trial
it's free for as long as you are a
curiosity stream member there just isn't
a better deal in streaming where you get
two great streaming sites with content
that you'll actually watch and enjoy for
less than 15 per year at its current
sales price but what's more is signing
up will actually help countless
independent educational creators beyond
just legal eagle so sign up now by
clicking on this button that's here on
screen right now or you can click on the
link that's down below in the
description it's a great way to support
educational content and get tons of
exclusive content that you'll love so
click right now and after you do that
click on this playlist over here for
more legal eagle videos so click here or
i'll see you in court